[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo refait toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine bonjour katia bonjour
michael est avec nous cette semaine nous
accueillons pierre moscovici
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation êtes commissaire
européen chargé des affaires économiques
et financières de la fiscalité et des
douanes pour être tout à fait complet on
va bien sûr parler d'europe avec vous
puisque cette semaine jean claude
juncker a dévoilé ses plans pour
construire une europe sans les
britanniques on reviendra sur les
propositions des manuels macron de
marine le pen pour l'europe dont vous
demandera de façon plus générale quel
est votre sentiment sur la situation
politique à 50 jours des élections
françaises et donc on a commencé par
l'actualité politique française
on va commencer avec françois fillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lâché par une partie de ses troupes
menacé d'être mise en examen françois
fillon avait tenté une nouvelle fois de
relancer sa campagne on va tout seul
avec stéphanie des pierres après
plusieurs heures de suspense et les
rumeurs les plus folles
françois fillon monte sur l'estrade à
ses côtés visage crispé des ténors de la
droite valérie pécresse françois baroin
bruno retailleau eric woerth françois
fillon annonce qu'il est convoqué chez
les juges d'instruction pour être mise
en examen le 15 mars prochain soit deux
jours avant la clôture des candidatures
à la présidentielle
je ne céderai pas je ne me rendrais pas
je ne me retirerai pas j'irai jusqu'au
bout parce qu'au delà de ma personne
c'est la démocratie qui est défiée je
vous demande de me suivre
le 26 janvier dernier sur tf1 françois
fillon avait déclaré qu'il ne serait pas
candidat s'il était mis en examen
aujourd'hui plus question d'abandonner
le candidat de la droite persiste dans
son offensive contre la justice
il dénonce une enquête à charge et un
calendrier judiciaire trop politique
c'est un assassinat en effet mais par ce
déchaînement disproportionnée sans
précédent connu par le choix de ce
calendrier
ce n'est pas moi seulement qu'on
assassine c'est l'élection
présidentielle une diatribe contre les
juges reprises par les quelques
parlementaires présents à sa conférence
de presse
c'est une procédure exclusivement à
charge exclusivement contre lui comme si
l'on voulait priver les électeurs de la
droite et du centre d'un candidat qui a
de l'autorité des convictions je dis que
la démocratie est attaquée et que les
juges auraient dû et devrait
réfléchir avant d'agir aussi brutalement
malgré l'appel à la résistance de
françois fillon l'unité de la droite
facile
bruno le maire son conseiller spécial
pour les affaires internationales
démissionne de l'équipe de campagne
plusieurs députés d'élus mais restée des
sarkozystes refuse désormais de soutenir
françois fillon les centristes de l'udf
eux ont suspendu leur participation à la
campagne de françois fillon
carlos qu'officier vous voyez le
contexte de cette campagne notamment à
droite pour le candidat françois fillon
c'est du déjà-vu pour vous non je suis
pas le mieux placé pour parler de la
campagne électorale française parce que
nous avions rendez vous voyez c'est
parce que d'une part je suis commissaire
européen je travaille avec le prochain
président quel qu'il soit d'autre part
je ne suis pas de la famille politique
de françois fillon mais je peux vous
donner le sentiment qu'on éprouve du
coup vu de bruxelles
oui du jamais vu avec une campagne qui
pour le moment n'est pas une campagne
centrée sur le fond et avec une famille
politique la famille politique du centre
droit qui se trouve dans un très grand
désarroi est incapable de développer un
projet et est ramené à des sujets qui
sont des sujets judiciaire avec c'est
vrai ce sentiment d'une très grande
division de cette famille d'une très
grande volonté avouée de 2,2 vraiment
continuer de françois fillon
malgré une procédure judiciaire qui dans
d'autres pays
ouais c'est quoi cette révélation encore
une fois je ne veux pas moi me prononcer
avec un chapeau manière à vous
comprendre votre réserve
vous avez été directeur de campagne pour
françois hollande en 2012 je vais le
dire 'tiens mine je vais lire
différemment je suis un homme de gauche
je suis un européen
je suis un français et il est important
que la famille de la droite et du centre
c'est une famille politique importante
puisse mener campagne en développant un
projet en ayant sa forme d'unité autour
d'un candidat qui va de l'avant et là on
voit bien qu'elle est entravée et dès
lors que cette famille politique est
entravée il y à quelque chose
d'essentiel qui manque au débat
politique en france et c'est un homme de
gauche de conviction
quelqu'un qui a été un ministre de la
france pendant sept ans qui vous le dit
on a besoin la gestuelle la france est
tellement essentiel à l'union européenne
cette élection est tellement importante
pour la france qu'on a besoin d'un vrai
d'un grand débat d'idées d'un vrai choix
de société et aussi d'un vrai choix pour
l'europe
là manifestement ce qui se passe et qui
plus qu'une péripétie entrave la
campagne présidentielle sème le trouble
sème le doute
et j'ajoute une chose c'est que on est
parfois bien inspirés de regarder ce qui
se passe à bruxelles parce que je suis
ici dans l'enceinte du parlement
français j'ai été député à l'assemblée
nationale française et je sais que au
parlement européen ça fait une dizaine
d'années qu'on ne peut pas employer des
proches ou des membres de sa famille et
je sais aussi que par exemple quand on
est commissaire européen touche un
salaire qui est tout à fait confortable
parce qu'il faut aussi bien payé les
élus et des responsables ne peut pas
avoir la moindre activité à côté ni
toucher le moindre revenu à côté pas un
centime et je trouve sa finale en même
temps que ça comme un temps ça peut
tenir les autres niveaux une
moralisation de la vie politique
française
jusqu'où on peut aller avec ce contexte
politique que nous vivons aujourd'hui
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais je peux pas
en dire jusqu'où ça peut aller jusqu'où
ça peut aller
est ce que ça aurait dû déjà allés
jusque là et ce spectacle et d'un
spectacle qui je crois désoriente
beaucoup de français il durcit certains
d'entre eux il est accablant
tant le débat politique à l'extrême il
crée des frictions entre le pouvoir
politique et la justice alors même que
la justice doit être respecté dans son
fonctionnement
on est déjà loin c'est déjà aller loin
alors cette semaine et ce n'est pas à
moi de me prononcer sur tel ou tel
candidat de la droite
j'aime sur vos joueurs d'alain juppé
pour vous ça serait pareil mais non
sébastien question qui se pose
aujourd'hui
non mais ce que je souhaite ce que je
souhaite comme français comme européen
c'est que le débat politique puisse
maintenant concernant cette situation ce
marché et que on est une situation qui
soit la situation
plus lisible justement un ambigu plus
clair
mais après c'est à la droite de régler
cette question par rapport aux
procédures et avec ses propres champions
on va parler justement d'un programme
qui a été dévoilée cette semaine et
celui d' emmanuel macron le candidat de
en marche a dévoilé son projet au
pavillon gabriel à paris à quelques
mètres de l'elysée entre liberté et
protection revoyons avec l amont à gaza
quelles sont les grandes lignes de ce
programme un projet présidentiel
articulée autour de plusieurs chantiers
tout d'abord l'éducation et la culture
emmanuel macron propose notamment de
limiter à douze élèves les classes de cp
et de ce1 dans les zones prioritaires
sur le travail beaucoup de mesures
la réforme de l'assurance chômage elle
ne sera plus financées par les
cotisations mais par la csg qui du coup
augmenterait les droits au chômage
seront ouverts aux indépendants et aux
démissionnaires
en contrepartie de refus d' offres
valables d'emploi équivaudront à une
radiation
autre annonce inédite cette fois la fin
des régimes spéciaux de retraite
la montée en charge complète elle prend
dix ans parce que progressivement ce
sont des générations après générations
et bien ce système de cotisations et de
droits ouverts en transparence en
parfaite égalité qui prend le dessus sur
les régimes actuels ce qui fait que oui
cela conduira à la suppression des
régimes spéciaux et donc l'intégralité
les je crois 37 caisses de retraite qui
aujourd'hui existe et bien convergeront
dans un système unique où chaque euro
versé donnera les mêmes droits en
matière de prestations enfin la création
d'emplois francs chaque entreprise qui
embauchera un jeune en cdi
issus des quartiers dits politiques de
la ville recevra une prime de 15 mille
euros sur trois ans jusqu'à présent et
depuis le début nous avons toujours
décidé d'aider les quartiers c'est à
dire d'assigner à résidence les jeunes
qui était née dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles de la république la
philosophie que nous revenons est
profondément différente
elle consiste en quelque sorte à donner
la possibilité à chaque jeunes issus de
ces quartiers d'avoir une aide
spécifique
en matière de fiscalité emmanuel macron
entend taxer davantage les assurances
vie et promet par ailleurs une
exonération de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des français d'ici à 2020 sans
priver les collectivités territoriales
de ce financement
c'est un impôt qui est payé
indépendamment du revenu excepté pour
les plus modestes d'entre nous qui sont
aujourd'hui exonérés
mais qui lorsqu'on gagne 1 ou 2 smic est
le même que lorsqu'on gagne 5 ou 6 smic
pour un logement si celui-ci ait les
mêmes caractéristiques dans la même
ville il n'est donc pas juste sur le
plan social il n'est pas non plus juste
sur le plan territorial
un chapitre est également ouvert sur la
modernisation de la vie politique chère
à son allié françois bayrou l'ancien
ministre de l'économie veut interdire
aux parlementaires de cumuler leur
mandat avec des activités de conseil
enfin sur l'europe et l'international
emmanuel macron veut redonner aux
français confiance en l'union européenne
alors pierre moscovici et manuel macro
est l'un des rares à s'être engagée à
maintenir le déficit public dans la
fourchette autorisée des 3%
et pourtant il propose beaucoup de
choses 50 milliards d'investissements de
remboursement des lunettes des prothèses
etc etc
dix mille policiers gendarmes recruter
comment espérer avec tous à tenir cette
fourchette strictes
je vais être trois ans max d'abord la
première c'est que on avait beaucoup
demandez le programme
ouh là là on l'a et que finalement il
sera un de ceux qui leur ont donné le
plus tôt et le plus complet donc il a au
moins ce mérite d'avoir maintenant sur
la table un projet un programme complète
dont on peut débattre et c'est
précisément ce qu'on a besoin d'un grand
débat démocratique sur des projets et
des programmes deuxième chose ce
programme est fidèle ce qu'il a dit
c'est à dire qu'il est il a dit ni
droite ni gauche et droite et gauche et
les éléments de continuité les mondes
changement il ya les éléments droitier
des aimants de gauche et donc il va
falloir apprécié nous ça moi
personnellement je reste un homme de
gauche dash est un programme de gauche
mais il ya là vous vous trouvez dans le
programme il ya des idées de gauche dans
lequel on a retrouvé les idées de droite
dans lequel je me retrouve pas mais je
veux dire c'est du solide supra
questionné en tout cas ils découlent
un travail qui lui est un travail solide
et douane ils méritent d'être examinées
débattu avec des points de désaccord et
les points d'accord et moi ma troisième
remarque elle est pour l'europe en effet
un des mérites des manuels macron est
d'avoir compris que la france n'avait
aucun intérêt à perdre du crédit
politique et économique en europe et
qu'il fallait en effet poursuivre dans
la voie des progrès qui ont été
enregistrés et sur la compétitivité et
sur la crédibilité budgétaire
aujourd'hui la france en 2007 peut
passer devrait passer en dessous de 3%
que c'est un bon candidat et qu'on vous
dise donc non non je vais jusqu'au bout
si vous permettez pas ce que je vais
essayer d'être un peu plus
enfin que cela parce que je le louis non
jeu télévisé où on vient je suis
d'accord je pas d'accord ça va pas donc
je pense que ça c'est bien et que
s'engager à respecter les critères
s'engager à poursuivre la voie du
désendettement s'engager à poursuivre la
voie de la réduction des déficits est
aussi avancée sur la construction d'une
union économique et monétaire est ravie
avec l'allemagne ça me paraît dans le
bon sens derrière ça il ya une question
qui est essentiel c'est le comment et en
effet il ne suffit pas de dire qu'on va
respecter les déficits il faut montrer
quelle est la cohérence entre les
dépenses qui sont mises en avant d'un
côté les recettes qui peuvent venir de
l'autre le scénario incroyable de
minutes quand vous regardez donc là
c'est un peu comme au tennis si vous
voulez il ya la conception du geste et
puis il ya la finalisation et contout et
dans la finalisation
mais je veux dire par là que là il
faudra qu'on examine ça de près mais
encore une fois l'intention européenne
ou d'aucune attention candidats de leur
accorder salomon le seul sait quand
c'est le candidat qui dans la campagne
européenne dans la campagne
présidentielle a mis le plus en avant
l'europe et qui essaye de faire une
pédagogie vers les français que l'europe
est bonne pour la france et que la
france a besoin de l'europe que l'europe
a aussi besoin de la france
et ça c'est un mérite que je lui
reconnais depuis longtemps après mon
candidat à moi qui suis un homme de
gauche et un homme européen
c'est celui qui est capable de marier
ces deux aspirations et je souhaite
franchement que dans la pratique on soit
capable d'avoir une europe qui non
seulement soit économiquement plus
pertinente mais qui soit capable de
résoudre
divergence divergences nées dans une
pierre moscovici je vous envoie et qui
soit aussi capable de réduire les
inégalités et 2 ce point de vue là je
n'ai pas aujourd'hui de programme
vous n'avez pas aujourd'hui votre
candidat de gauche présents à cette
élection présidentielle qui foutent
marierait ces deux options mais si tu ne
retrouvait pas de candidat c'est pour ce
qui me concerne je constate qu'il ya une
chose c'est que la gauche
sociale-démocrate européenne n'a pas de
candidat dans cette élection
après dans une élection on prend aussi
ceux qui se présentent et on fait des
choix en fonction après votre joueur on
doit on doit examiner les programmes
j'attends les programmes des autres
puisque finalement d'une certaine façon
emmanuel macron a pris les devants entre
je vois ce qu'il propose je vois la
cohérence je vois c'est une démarche
qu'il faut adopter çà la démarche qui
consiste à présenter un projet à
discuter et débattre de sa cohérence et
que dans ce projet il ya une partie
européenne substantielle donc voilà je
ne suis pas en marche mais je respecte
la démarche qui étaient présentes il est
l'héritier du la social démocratie à la
françois hollande il ya des éléments
continuité je les dis aussi les éléments
qui sont des éléments de différencier
les mondes gauche et droite donc il
prend une partie l'héritage ce qu'il
était c'est logique puisqu'il a comme
jouer un rôle dans tout ça il a été
conseiller du président il a été
ministre à ce titre et kiev d'héritier
mais s'il n'est pas l'héritier de la
gauche sociale démocrate ou simplement
parce que lui-même refuse de se mettre
dans cette position est que il construit
une formation politique qui a plus dans
viva lancent certains diraient
d'ambiguïté c'est son choix en tout cas
il l'assumé il le poursuit et ça mérite
à tout le moins d'être considérés
respectés examiné vous parrainerait
quelqu'un pour cette année quelqu'un
dire je suis plus élu je ne peux pas
parler qui que ce soit et vous bien ce
sera un sujet embarrassant pour moi m'a
parlé d'europe
si vous voulez lire il faudra peut-être
aussi de parler d'un autre candidat qui
est celui du parti socialiste
on va y arriver à gaza de la station est
toujours socialiste bien évidemment est
ce que ce que le parti socialiste où
s'en va le dire en europe ça m'intéresse
également et on va parler d'europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va parler de l'europe et notamment
des déclarations de marine le pen cette
semaine qui fustige la politique
agricole commune a été de passage
évidemment au salon de l'agriculture
elle est également sur le plateau de la
chaîne parlementaire elle veut remplacer
la politique agricole commune par une
politique agricole française sur les
gouttes mais je supprime pas la pac
était un moment donné il faut quand même
faire preuve de bon sens nous versons 20
milliards on nous en rang vous même 21
milliards presque on nous en rang 13 pas
comprises bon et bien on récupère nos 20
milliards et on maintient évidemment les
aides quitte d'ailleurs à les augmenter
un peu à l'agriculture mais en revanche
on change les critères puisque la
voiture moment où francis ces aides
c'est nous qui allons décider des
critères française et lezennes
vous répondez quoi marine le pen le
projet de marine le pen sur l'europe il
est simple c'est la fin c'est la fin de
l'union européenne c'est la sortie de la
france de l'union européenne et c'est la
mort de l'union européenne et je dis que
c'est un projet qui est à la fois
dangereux pour l'europe mortel pour
l'europe est suicidaire pour la france
voyez je ne ménage pas je pense que
c'est un vrai crime politique
la france a besoin de l'europe la france
ne trouve sa place dans le monde que
dans l'europe
nous sommes dans un moment où il ya des
menaces qui se profilent
il ya des nouveaux présidents américains
il ya un président russe et on voudrait
donner la main à ceux qui souhaite
diviser l'europe par ailleurs l'europe
et notre ouverture au monde
nous avons 70 % nos échanges avec
l'europe et s'agissant des agriculteurs
j'étais moi aussi au salon ils savent
tous ce qu'il doit à l'europe et la
thèse de la francisation des aides
parce qu'elle
ça va coûter 20 milliards qui sont pour
solde de tout compte et de l'autre côté
la politique et récolter ce que je vous
ai précisé
c'est à c'est un tour de passe-passe qui
du charlatanisme
j'ajoute que si la france venait à
sortir de l'union européenne et la zone
euro en particulier ça se traduirait par
défaut de la france par une sorte de
faillite du pays par une hausse massive
des taux d'intérêt de l'inflation par un
appauvrissement des français et les
premiers qui seraient les victimes se
sont noyées je suis indignée ce qu'elle
prétend représenter ce sont les plus
modestes
ce sont les plus pauvres ce sont ceux
qui ont besoin d'emprunter pour vivre ce
sont ceux qui sont avec une part de la
consommation dans leurs revenus la plus
élevée ce sont les plus modestes sont
les couches populaires les couches
moyennes qui serait victime de son
projet donc je combats radicalement ce
que dit madame le pen sur l'europe
rien de ce qu'elle dit n'est solide rien
de ce qu'elle dit n'est vrai tout ce
qu'elle dit est dangereux alors on va
rester sur l'union européenne qui tente
d'organiser son avenir sans les
britanniques
ce mercredi le chef de la commission
européenne jean claude juncker a
présenté un livre blanc avec plusieurs
routes d'avenir possible pour l'europe
recentrage sur le marché unique ou l
inverse élargissement du transfert de
compétences vers l'union européenne
pierre moscovici se livrer et blanc
c'est à dire que tout reste à écrire
il ya cinq plans 5 route 7 5 voix on a
du mal à y voir clair quelle est la
bonne route pour vous si vous en avez
dans ce livre n'est pas blanc c'est la
première fois que la commission
européenne entré il ya plusieurs fait un
constat lucide de ce qui va et ce qui ne
va pas en europe
on nous reproche souvent d'être où les
gens qui sont les européens qui disent
y'a qu'il n'ya qu'un chemin voilà le bon
tout va bien non tout nouveau stade et
lille europe aujourd'hui elle est
menacée par les crises elle est dans un
environnement jeu politique compliquée
et elle est aussi touchée par des
divergences économiques et des
inégalités qu'il faut résoudre et nous
sommes lucides là dessus après nous
avons souhaité offrir aux chefs d'état
et de gouvernement puisque c'est le 60e
anniversaire de cette robe aux
parlementaires et je souhaite qu'il ya
débat parlementaire sur ces sujets là
aux citoyens un outil pour la réflexion
et plusieurs scénarios on peut
continuez comme aujourd'hui je pense que
ce serait dommage parce que le statu quo
n'est pas suffisant on peut se réduire
au marché intérieur
je pense que ce serait aussi dommage
parce que si on fait ça on néglige la
dimension culturelle sociale spirituelle
éducative de l'union européenne on peut
réduire les compétences ce serait la
défaisance de l'union européenne je
pense que nous serions pas à la hauteur
des enjeux il c'est horrible à bonn peut
envisager d une europe à géométrie
variable
dernière piste c'est celle d'un sursaut
européen
on est capable de faire pas seulement
plus mais surtout beaucoup mieux
ensemble et c'est britannique
de toute façon on est en train de
construire l'europe à 27 que la
grande-bretagne sortir l'union
européenne c'est évidemment ce dernier
scénario qui a ma préférence mais je
souhaite qu'il soit débattu et on va
chez les ré vous accélérez sur cette
question et on va accélérer son
entraîneur on n'accélère pas sur ces on
a notre rythme et tout ça doit être la
bouche des buttes débouché en septembre
sur un plan d'action en vue la mission
benedet et a revu les premiers vous avez
parlé de la gauche et de beaux hommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine benoît hamon avait donné
rendez-vous à ses troupes une salle du
10e arrondissement à paris le même jour
manuel valls eut déjeuné avec ses
proches
près de l'assemblée nationale on voit
tout le résumé de cette semaine à gauche
valérie et brochard est la bande à gaza
tous derrière le vainqueur de la
primaire socialiste pas si simple benoît
hamon le sait sa ligne politique son
accord avec europe ecologie les verts ne
font pas l'unanimité
alors pour rassurer l'ensemble des
parlementaires socialistes
le candidat à la présidentielle les a
conviés dans une salle parisienne pour
une mise au point
la tonalité c'est de reprendre un
certain nombre de sujets le contenu de
l'accord avec les écologistes de
détailler certains points sur le
nucléaire sûr aussi le 49-3 citoyens la
réforme des institutions
voilà de répondre à des interrogations
qui ont été posées par un certain nombre
de parlementaires et d'y répondre avec
des arguments et d'expliquer y compris
de lever certains malentendus parce
qu'il ya des choses parfois qu'ils sont
mal comprises donc là c'est un rapport
direct avec les parlementaires pour dire
franchement ce qu'il pense par rapport à
la laïcité par rapport à l'europe par
rapport à tous les sujets qui sont dans
la campagne et qui seront dans la
campagne
seulement voilà ce qu'ils expriment leur
défiance vis-à-vis du programme de
benoît hamon n'étaient pas très nombreux
à cette réunion
les réformateurs ont préféré répondre à
l'appel de leur chef manuel valls un peu
plus tard dans la journée
l'ailé droite du parti socialiste
souhaite se faire entendre et le pôle
social démocrate est une réalité dans le
parti socialiste est alors que le danger
le pen pointe
on a besoin de d'entendre manuel valls
un peu de gêne à rendez-vous pas
toujours assumé devant les caméras les
valses east ne se sentent pas très à
l'aise avec l'idée de se retrouver en
dehors des réunions proposées par
l'équipe de benoît hamon
mais un ancien candidat à la primaire
socialiste insiste ce n'est pas une
fraude
jason d'une réunion de ce qu ont
participé à la primaire
c'est une réunion qui est on a déjà eu
deux ou trois comme ça monsieur valls
était pas là mais des représentants de
monsieur varela monsieur didier
guillaume par exemple qui sont ceux qui
ont participé à la primaire et qui
souhaitent participer pleinement à la
campagne de benoît hamon je deviens
campagne de buzz
pourtant l'entourage politique de
l'ancien premier ministre est quasiment
absent de l'équipe de campagne de benoît
hamon
réunis dans la salle colbert de
l'assemblée nationale les réformateurs
ont exprimé leur déception parfois même
leur tentation de rallier emmanuel
macron pour sa part manuel valls s'est
dit prêt à jouer collectif
à condition que benoît hamon bouge sa
ligne jugée trop radicale
ma désireux de finir on va nous
rejoindre dans un instant mais perd
moscovici il faudrait vous entendre sur
le programme de benoît hamon et
notamment cette question de la dette
il a dit cette semaine qu'il ne veut
plus rembourser la dette
mais la renégocier est ce acceptable
quand on est commissaire européen qui
plus est de gauche je vais m'exprimer
comme commissaire européen vie vous
posez des balkans est mettre de côté mes
préférences politiques une seconde à
vous voulez parler d'agos nous avons ouï
mais je parlerai aussi de la gauche
après mais il ya des choses qui sont des
règles qui ont été communément acceptées
par les européens nous devons réduire
nos déficits
le chiffre de 3% n'est pas un chiffre
arbitraire il a dirigé un non sens
économique c'est un chiffre qui permet
précisément d'être celui qui stoppe la
spirale de l'endettement
l'endettement de la france est trop
élevé ils étaient 97 % il peut baisser
vers 90 % à conditions que nous passions
durablement en dessous de 3% et ce que
j'attends du prochain président français
qui qu'il soit c'est que il y est le
maintien de cette crédibilité économique
et budgétaire française c'est ça qui
permettra de combat 2d prose buzz et ça
qui permettra de convaincre nos amis
allemands d'aller de l'avant notamment
vers une zone euro plus intégré un
budget de la zone euro perd plus
d'investissements en europe vers plus de
convergence en europe
donc ça vaut pour tous le rsa vaut aussi
pour benoît moi je pense que le respect
des règles et de salubrité publique et
d'intérêt général etc si sur ce point
mais c'est pas la question de menacer
les françaises ont un débat c'est juste
de rappeler à certains de mes rêves qui
sont d'intérêt et qui sont candidats
d'autres partis ne respectent pas les
rues diable choses sur la dette
je pense qu'il ya à la fois lorsque ni
benoît hamon un point qui est pertinente
que ne pouvons pas vivre pendant les
cinq années qui viennent en remboursant
la dette mais c'est un problème qui
n'est pas un problème national
c'est un problème qui est un problème
collectif dès lors quand j'évoque l'idée
d'un budget de la zone euro l'idée
une forme de mutualisation et surtout
nous avons un peu réfléchir là dessus
oui mais c'est de ça dont je parle
puisque cette prise de position qu'il
évoque mais pour le reste
l'idée qu'on ne rembourserait pas la
dette française ne me paraît pas
pertinente parce que la dette française
est une dette qui n'est pas cher avec
des taux d'intérêt qui sont
historiquement bas
elle n'est pas excessive le crédit de la
france est solide et toutes mesures de
refus de remboursement de la dette
serait perçue par les marchés et par les
acteurs financiers comme une forme de
défaut et entraînerait immédiatement en
retour des formes de représailles dont
la manifestation serait d'abord la
hausse des taux d'intérêt et je pense
que la france ils seraient perdantes
nous n'avons pas en france nous avons un
problème de dynamique de la dette qu'il
faut inverser nous n'avons pas de
problème de stock de dettes et le dé
l'annulation de la dette
le renoncement la dette n'est pas je
crois la solution pour le pays
je le dis de la manière la plus claire
enfin crédibilité des finances publiques
est un atout pour le pays et pour la
gauche c'est un atout aussi et quand on
est de gauche on doit rassembler toute
la gauche
alors on va continuer à parler de devant
le socialiste on va continuer à en
parler avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
at il tire au bonjour c'est à vous
bonjour katia bonjour michael bonjour
pierre moscovici alors vous l'avez dit
vous voulez parler de benoît hamon on va
en parler cette semaine on l'a dit les
valses east ont fait parler d'eux on
voit que le candidat socialiste a du mal
à rassembler son propre camp
est ce que vous craignez une
décomposition de votre parti avec d'un
côté les réformistes qui pourraient
faire défection et de l'autre côté ce
candidat benoît hamon qui représente en
fait qui est minoritaire dans son parti
je suivais le niveau 6 ni hamonistes et
je n'ai pas pris parti de dans la
primaire du parti socialiste mais très
volontaire pour des raisons à la fois de
substance et pour des raisons de forme
qui sont liées à ce que je fais
aujourd'hui mais j'ai une petite
expérience j'étais notamment le
directeur de la dernière campagne
présidentielle il se trouve c'est une
campagne qui a gagné je sais qu'il ya
une règle de base dans le parti
socialiste qui est de rassembler les
siens je comprends que dans un mois son
projet avec ces éléments de novation et
c'est absolument naturel je comprends
qu'il ait souhaité un accord avec les
écologistes
mais il faut aussi que l'ensemble du
parti socialiste se reconnaissent dans
son candidat soit derrière son candidat
marche derrière son candidat n'est pas
le gars soit avec son candidat et que
les inquiétudes les doutes soit entendu
et compris qu'on s'efforce de bâtir un
projet qui puisse entraîner tout le
monde parce que une campagne ça se gagne
avec tout le monde derrière soi et puis
à pays ça se dirige avec une formation
politique qui se reconnaît dans le
projet du candidat dont je pense que cet
effort d'ajustement fort à faire le
parti ne l'aide pas vraiment est-ce que
l'effort doit être faite du côté de la
part du candidat benoît hamon ou de la
part justement du parti socialiste et de
ses cadres et de l'effort doit être fait
par tous en vérité ceux qui n'ont pas
gagné la primaire doit me respecter le
vainqueur de la primaire d'abord en le
reconnaissant comme leur candidat
c'est naturel et pour moi je suis pas
dans cette
aventure là mais aussi en se
reconnaissant dans le projet qui est le
sien et lui doit faire en sorte que le
projet qui est le sien permettre
l'adhésion de tous à dire que ça
s'appelle le rassemblement et c'est la
règle de base de tout ce qu'implique
pour une campagne qui est soit réussie
nous reste qu est ce que vous craignez
que le parti socialiste disparaissent
après cette élection présidentielle si
si et benoît hamon la paire cette
élection non le parti socialiste est une
idée vial une idée qui est une idée de
multi séculaire qui applique chante en
tout cas dans une existence partisane et
on aura toujours besoin dans un pays
comme la france d' une gauche qui soit
une gauche de gouvernement une gauche de
transformation gauche de réduction des
inégalités une gauche qui soit aussi
européennes et d'une gauche qui soit
capable de diriger le pays
nous vivons un moment de crise de crise
politique le parti socialiste connaît
aussi sa crise c'est pas la peine de le
nier et il sait pas le seul symptôme ce
qui se passe au ps c'est aussi la montée
des manuels macro et d'autres phénomènes
la poussée de jean luc mélenchon il
faudra que le parti socialiste soit
capable de se rénover profondément après
cette élection
mais avant il ya l'élection je pense que
le parti socialiste doit être capable de
proposer aux français une plate forme
qui soit une plate forme à la fois
original mais crédible mais européenne
merci pierre moscovici dans avec notre
invité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
sacs chaussures ceinture peu importe les
prix exorbitants
les peaux de python font fureur dans les
boutiques occidentales mais les
critiques quant aux conditions de chasse
d'abattage et aux salaires dérisoires
des petites mains du secteur sont de
plus en plus présente les dessous de la
mondialisation
demain à 21h30 sur public sénat public
sénat
au coeur du débat